un sistema de vigilancia masiva para
rastrear a los integrantes de La minoría
otros musulmanes y turcos a través de
sus teléfonos inteligentes eso es lo que
revela el más reciente informe de Human
Rights watch la ong ha revisado una
lista de archivos utilizados por el
gobierno chino que enumera lo que
califican de contenido violento o
terrorista
hemos contabilizado 50.000 archivos cuyo
contenido se considera violento o
terrorista algunos de estos datos si son
violentos por ejemplo las ejecuciones
que realiza el grupo estado islámico sin
embargo la mayoría son solo rezos
islámicos como audios grabados y videos
del Corán los archivos figuran en una
base de datos de las autoridades chinas
que fue utilizada entre 2015 y 2019 por
la policía de urunki la capital de
shingán para llevar a cabo operaciones
de vigilancia e incluso arrestos así lo
publica la revista de intercept todo
ello bajo la ley antiterrorista que
facilita los enjuiciamientos la
privación de la libertad y otras
restricciones por motivos políticos
religiosos o ideológicos
por su parte la policía china afirma que
los teléfonos denunciados sí contenían
archivos violentos son exactamente las
mismas autoridades que negaban la
existencia de los llamados campos de
reeducación de wiigures en shingyang
estimamos en alrededor de 500.000 el
número de ubigures y musulmanes turcos
que siguen detenidos dentro de estos
pseudocampos de reeducación o en las
prisiones e incluso quienes están en
libertad viven en condiciones en las que
todos sus movimientos son escrutados lo
que los impulsa a esconder su religión e
identidad cultural
la organización acusa al gobierno chino
de practicar una amalgama peligrosa
entre el islam y el extremismo violento
para justificar los abusos contra los
musulmanes y llamó a abrir una
investigación internacional
independiente